[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN BENNETT: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Jen Bennett,
technical director
and the office's CTO.
And I'm thrilled to be joined
by Jon Sobel, the CEO of Sight
Machine, one of Google
Cloud's partners.
Today, we're going to
be talking about getting
manufacturing companies started
on digital transformation.
Just as a reminder, you
can ask questions any time
on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
So manufacturing is going
through a revolution.
We hear about industry
4.0, smart manufacturing,
whatever the name might be.
But the reality is the same
kind of revolution that we saw,
the digital revolution that
we saw in the consumer space
when we connected billions
of people and devices,
is the same sort of revolution
that we're going through now
within the manufacturing space.
And at the core of
that revolution,
it's really about
personalization.
And we're starting
to see that now come
to life in manufacturing
in mass customization
and being able to personalize
products and services.
And so with that, we look
at spaces like consumer
where we've seen some
of the technology that
evolved to adapt and to be able
to make that mass customization
affordable.
And so we're going
to talk a little bit
about the technology, but it's
not just about technology.
It's also about people,
the process, the culture.
And at the core
of this technology
and this transformation,
it's really about data.
And part of the
cultural shift is
becoming a really
data-driven organization
and being able to leverage the
data to drive personalization
and customization.
And so with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Jon
to give a talk to
us a little bit more
about what they're seeing
in this space and some
of the technology that
you guys have built
to enable manufacturers
to go on this journey
of digital transformation.
JON SOBEL: Thank you, Jen.
I'm going to share a little
background about data
in the manufacturing industry
and then, as Jen suggests,
talk a little bit about how
companies who are effectively
using it are doing so.
First off, I think many of our
guests will appreciate this.
Those of you in manufacturing
know this to be true.
Manufacturing generates more
data than any other industry.
We think of digital
data as fuel,
as an opportunity for insight.
There is twice as much
data in manufacturing
as in any other
category in business.
And, as those of you who
work in factories know,
this is what we do.
This is how we make
factories work.
You see the picture
of the white board.
It's incredibly frustrating to
manufacturers to have so much
digital data available--
the data that's generated
by automation, by all the
controls and software that you
find in a factory--
and the best we've been
able to do in most places
is the daily or weekly scrum
and the white board session.
And we do a pretty good job.
Factories run very well.
They make complicated
stuff effectively.
But there's so much opportunity
we can use the data that's
being generated.
And that's really the focus of
the technology behind Google
Cloud and what companies
like us are doing.
A little bit more
landscape here--
data is useful and going
to be useful in a way that
really goes to the heart of
the future of manufacturing.
We think about the United States
as a manufacturing economy.
We benefited after World War
II from a temporary aberration.
The great industrial
economies of the world
were sidelined by World War II.
Germany and Japan
both spent 30 years
rebuilding their economies.
And in the years since, China
has become the world's largest
manufacturer.
So there is a global contest
for manufacturing leadership.
And companies and countries
are investing heavily
in the next wave of innovation,
which is about data.
And data is useful for
every level of the game.
At the most basic
and the daily level,
the things that manufacturers
think about every day--
getting visibility
into your operations
into your supply chain,
keeping your factories
running as planned,
getting efficiency,
and getting control of quality--
these are perennial problems
that data is incredibly
effective for using.
And then if we think about
everything else going
on-- robotics, 3D printing,
sustainability-- data
informs all of this.
And at the highest
level, the transformation
that companies are
going through-- you
see some of the
leaders out there
talking about manufacturing
as a service, micro factories.
All of this depends on
having control of data.
JEN BENNETT: You know,
Jon, you talked about data.
And we talked about
the volume of data.
But really, the
problem's only getting
worse because as
Gartner had measured,
you have seen about 8.4 billion
devices connected in 2017, up
31%.
But we're seeing an even larger
growth coming in the future
by 2020--
the 20 billion devices,
something on the order of that.
So this data that you're talking
about is only getting bigger.
JON SOBEL: You're right, Jen.
I'm looking in the
rear-view mirror,
and the problem's only
going to get worse.
And so we need to use this data.
In contrast to other
categories, you
see things like smart
cities everyone talks about.
We've got to sensor
up the cities.
There's already plenty
of data in manufacturing.
And there's a really interesting
dynamic going on right now.
A couple of years ago, the
real question on people's minds
was, should we do this?
Does it matter?
Companies have
decided that they're
going to invest in digital.
98% of enterprises
are investing.
They're doing things.
They're not going as
fast as they want,
and the question is why.
We work with some
great companies.
We work with a lot of companies
who are just getting started.
And we see three themes.
The first is the technology.
It's not as easy
as everybody says.
The effective use
of data requires
some real technical chops.
And so you need
partners like Google
and some of the great
emerging companies
out there to use the data.
That's a solvable problem.
The companies that
serve manufacturers
are themselves trying to figure
out how to get good at this.
So you've got to figure
out the business landscape.
And then perhaps the
most important variable
is the clients themselves--
the organizations.
Working with data
involves change.
And the most important
thing is operationalizing
this technology,
getting new ways
of working into your workflow.
And that's where companies are
either succeeding or failing.
It's all about the organization.
Here's some interesting
statistics on how long
companies are spending piloting.
This is from the World
Economic Forum and McKinsey.
More than 80% of companies
that are doing pilots
are spending a year or more.
And in a quarter of cases,
they're spending two years just
to pilot technologies.
Meanwhile, the companies
that are going fast
are going really fast, and
the gap between the leaders
and laggards is getting wider.
To give you a
sense of the scale,
we work with a lot of
enterprise manufacturers.
They're targeting $100
million a year-plus impact.
This is something
that can really make
a difference if you do it well.
And one of the things
we'll talk about
is how to do that, how
to be effective at this.
JEN BENNETT: One
quick question--
are you suggesting that
pilots aren't important?
JON SOBEL: No, sorry.
Pilots are important.
They're important as
a way to get started.
And you and I both know no
manufacturer is just going
to go to scale right away.
They got to try something.
But there is a difference
between just trying stuff
to try it and trying stuff
with a purpose and a plan.
And what the really effective
partners are insisting on
is that when you sit down
and plan out a program,
you get everybody around
the table-- operations
leaders, IT leadership,
corporate leadership-- and talk
about when this succeeds
or when we learn something,
what are we going to do?
How are we going to scale it?
JEN BENNETT: I think
that's a really good point.
What we've seen as well
is that it's not just
about technology for technology.
It's about technology solving
a really key business problem.
So good point.
JON SOBEL: That's one
of the great things
about the
manufacturing industry.
Our company is a
bunch of web heads
who grew up in the Midwest.
And most of us worked in
manufacturing growing up.
So we appreciate both worlds.
The great thing about
manufacturing for a technology
company is it's a skeptical,
practical industry.
It's about results.
It's about measuring things
and getting things done.
So you got to start
with what are we
going to fix, what are we
going to help make better,
and then work back to the tech.
Here's the technology
problem, and I'll
set this up really quickly.
Big data is often said
to mean the three Vs--
volume, velocity, and variety.
Your companies have limitless
amount of computing power.
You can handle any
volume of data,
any velocity of calculation.
But the variety is
the killer problem.
And manufacturing may be the
most varied data environment
that we find anywhere.
This is an example of
the kinds of equipment
you find inside of a factory.
And it's just a thin
slice of what's out there.
There's literally thousands
of data sources emitting
different kinds of data multiple
times a second all the time.
Companies have done the hard
work of getting it aggregated,
getting it into a lake.
But now, we've got to
figure out how to use it.
And that's really the challenge.
One of the paradigms
that we all go
to when we think
about this problem
is the software paradigm.
We all say, oh, I must need
some new software to do this.
That probably means I
gotta rewire my factory.
I've got to change everything.
That's the last thing a good
manufacturer wants to do.
They've spent decades.
Think about how hard
it is to make a car.
You spend decades
getting things dialed in.
And the last thing
you want to do
is go change the control
software or the software
that you've relied upon.
Good news-- this is not
really a software problem.
This is a data problem.
Data is ones and zeros.
It doesn't care where
it was generated,
and it doesn't really matter
what created the data.
What matters is getting
the data out and using it.
And with the advent of
technologies like AI and cloud,
it's a data paradigm.
So what we need to do
to help manufacturers
is get the zeros and
ones out and then
put them to work
with great tools that
can help us make sense of them.
If you do that well--
and this is very different.
If we go back for a
minute, the left side
is a software paradigm.
It's an application paradigm.
So everybody goes, I
need an application
that understands this problem.
But data, when
used correctly, is
effective for all kinds
of problems, even ones
we haven't thought of so far.
So if you think of the modern
manufacturing enterprise,
data is useful for everybody,
from the machine operator
who's trying to figure out
how to make things work better
during their shift all the way
up to corporate leadership.
We see a lot of companies
bringing on data scientists.
They're working with
process engineers.
Something as simple as evening
out the flow on a line,
getting rid of bottlenecks--
couple of percentage
point improvement.
It drops right to
the bottom line.
For an enterprise manufacturer,
we're talking about hundreds
of millions of
dollars a year just
from using our data better.
JEN BENNETT: Before
you move on, can
you talk a little bit about--
you've talked about
these different roles.
And some are on the IT side,
and some are on the OT side.
Maybe you can give our
audience a little bit
of an idea about what
you're seeing in this.
And we talk about the
convergence of IT and OT,
particularly in
manufacturing and around data
and making data ubiquitous and
giving access to data in places
maybe where they
didn't have it before.
Give me a little bit of a
sense of what you're seeing
in this IT, OT convergence.
JON SOBEL: There's a
lot to say about that.
I'll try to be brief.
IT, for many years,
has served the carpet--
the business processes, the
front part of the operation.
And then there's been this
kind of interesting gray area--
the concrete.
There's often connectivity
on the plant floor,
and there's a ton of data.
But hasn't really been thought
of as the domain of IT.
And so it's a bit
of a jump ball.
Who really should govern
and figure out how
to use data on the plant floor?
And so IT and OT teams are
starting to work together.
And they come at it from
very different perspectives.
IT leadership has often been
focused on security and control
and having a reliable network,
and operations leadership
is focused on getting more
product out the door faster.
And good companies
are figuring out
how to put these teams together.
A lot of IT leadership
is really starting
to focus on how to
drive the needle
and be helpful to
the business in ways
that IT has never really been
called upon to do before.
And operations
leadership is starting
to learn about technology.
It's very much a
work in progress.
We see all flavors of this.
We see some companies where
IT leadership is really
pushing hard for change.
We see some companies where
operations leaders are
basically saying to
their IT colleagues,
hey, if you don't get
this going for me,
I'm going to get
it going myself.
I need to do this.
And so it's going to be figured
out over the next couple years.
It's interesting.
JEN BENNETT: We
talk a lot in Google
around this idea of
data democratization--
and now, even in machine
learning democratization.
But what we've seen with some
of the manufacturers who have
really adopted this idea of
democratizing data is that
people who it was
very difficult--
engineers who it was difficult
to get data from the shop floor
before--
are now starting to be
able to get that data
and make better
decisions in their role.
Because of bringing in
that variety of data
to solve problems,
customer service
has been able to get better
data from the service side of it
or from the manufacturers side.
So I think some
of this technology
is evolving to a
place where now we
can make this data
available to all roles
and help them
improve what they do
with that availability of data.
JON SOBEL: Well, and this is
why the cloud is so important.
Let's just talk
about all the kind
of functions you just listed.
Everything in a
manufacturing enterprise,
from design,
engineering, production,
the performance of
products out in the field,
customer service, finance, sales
and monitoring-- zeros and ones
with all of that.
And companies want to
understand all that together.
Zoom out even one step further.
Let's talk about
the supply chain.
Why should the
boundaries of the firm
be the boundaries of
the data we look at?
It's all zeros and ones.
And if we do this well, we
can serve these stakeholders
and then everybody else who
might want to use the data.
And I agree with you.
This is a strategic asset.
This is not a
traditional IT problem.
This is a strategic capability.
If you can use your data
well, you got a real edge.
I give an example of a company
we started working with three
or four years ago that's
thinking exactly this way.
And it was a real opportunity
for us as a young company.
We had been working with some
great automotive manufacturers
who were very focused on
what to do in the plant.
And this company
came to us and said,
we've got five
contract manufacturer
scattered all across Asia.
Each one's got their
own IT environment.
There was a bunch of automation
in each of these facilities.
Can you go wire up
this automation,
slurp off the data
multiple times a second,
and give us visibility
into everything
happening in this supply chain?
And we've done that
for them and others.
And this is how
companies of the future
are going to think about data.
This is a root system
into their production.
Their contract manufacturers
get a view of what they do.
The OEM gets a
view of everybody.
And everybody can be
better because they
can see what's going on.
Some other examples-- we
get asked all the time,
how is this practical?
What does it do for me?
We recently finished working
in one of the world's largest
dairy companies.
They make cheese.
And there is an artisan aspect
to the production of cheese
that requires that you know
when to turn things on and off
in a very complicated process.
It's the same as if you're
making chemicals or oil.
There's a lot of wisdom
and tribal knowledge
about how to do this and
thousands of parameters
that have to be studied.
If you can know exactly
when to do something
because the data
tells you, that's
immediate impact
on the bottom line.
And this company expects to
realize 10% or 15% improvement
in the profitability
of this production
just because it's
using its data.
We've done some work recently
with huge amounts of robots.
One of the largest auto
plants in North America
has 300 robots assembling cars.
The robots generate
a ton of data.
And if they go down-- and they
go down more than you would
expect-- it costs real money.
So being able to know when is
that going to happen, how do we
stop it, how do we fix it--
the data is all there.
If we can use it, we can get
control of these problems.
JEN BENNETT: And you've given
us some examples of some pretty
large manufacturing
and can often
be very expensive to do
these types of projects.
I'm wondering-- and I firmly
believe that this is not just
for the large enterprises.
The technology has evolved to
a space where it's accessible.
So not only do we
have democratization,
it's accessible to
small to medium.
Maybe can give us a little bit
of insight into that as well.
JON SOBEL: Absolutely.
So a couple of comments there--
we have some terms we
use inside our company
to describe the fastest movers.
And we talk about gazelles.
They're often not the
largest companies.
They're nimble.
They want to use their data,
and they want to go fast.
And you're absolutely right.
This isn't just a game
for the biggest companies.
The other thing is
that technology really
has been democratized now.
We can spin up an app
and map data to it
and show you visibility
into your machines
in literally an hour or less.
That technology
is proliferating.
And just to throw
around a few stats,
there's over a million
factories in the United States,
more than a million in China,
more than a million in Europe.
A very healthy
percentage of those
are owned by small and
medium-sized enterprises.
And the technology to do this
is available for every company
on that spectrum.
We spend a lot of time studying
the organizations we work with.
And I just wanted
to call this out
in case you're interested
in assessing your company.
There is a lot of
talk about readiness,
and it's really interesting.
We go to companies.
And one of the
things we've learned
to do-- when you
bring new technology
into an organization, it's
important to think about
how are we going
to succeed at this.
Where should we start?
And we learned early on-- this
was an unexpected insight--
that even within
the same company,
every plant is very different.
And so you have widely
varying levels of readiness
within the same organization.
You'll see on this chart
there is a kink to the left.
On the y-axis is
organizational readiness.
On the x-axis is
technical readiness.
To our surprise,
what we learned was
the very best plants were
led with the right mindset.
They had a focus on data.
They valued data.
It didn't really matter what
their technical readiness
was as much as the mindset
of the organization
and the leadership.
And one of the best
plants we ever went into
was running on Excel.
They were running
on Excel, but they
understood the value of data.
And so we developed
over a period of years
and based on going
into hundreds of plants
an index that helps you
score where your plants are
and where to start.
And if there's one take-home
point, it's pick situations--
we talked about pilots
and getting things going--
pick situations where there's
some committed leadership
at the right levels.
There's so many people and
companies that have great idea.
The tradition of quality
of walking the genba
is that people in be plant
know more than anybody else
about what to do and
how to make it better.
So tap into that
wisdom and knowledge.
Make sure you have plant
leadership aligned.
And then strong
corporate leadership
is so important to knock down
roadblocks and support people.
There's all kinds of other
interesting cultural things
we might talk about.
Transparency can be wonderful.
If an organization really wants
to understand what it does well
and what it can be
better at, transparency
is incredibly powerful.
There are some
organizations that
struggle with transparency.
And so you have to really think
about where is the right place
to start.
How do we support
people when they find
problems we didn't know we had?
And how do we fix them?
And that leads to a
list of best practices.
There's a lot of
words on this slide.
I'll try to distill
the key ones.
We talked about
pilots with a focus
on getting to operational.
Making operational
use the acid test
is something that good
companies do right away.
It's one thing to try
technology just to experiment,
but we got to get going here.
And so thinking
about when this works
or when we learn
something, what are
we going to do to go to scale
separates companies that
are succeeding from others.
This is a change exercise.
We've seen a few companies--
another bullet point here
is about embracing change
as a discipline in itself.
I was shocked.
We went to a plant
recently in Australia.
And somebody introduced
herself and said,
I'm the change leader here.
I asked her, what's your job?
She said, I was hired to
help the technology people
talk to the operations people.
And I've seen this now
in two or three companies
in the last couple of months.
Companies are actually
thinking about how
do we bring this
into our operations,
how do we get people
talking to each other
and have designated
change leaders.
JEN BENNETT: I think
that's really interesting.
If you think about
lean manufacturing,
it really is the foundation
of agile software practices.
And yet, we've
kind of gotten away
from this idea of adaptability.
I know you and I have talked
about this quite a bit.
But the world is
changing faster than
even our manufacturing
clients can adapt.
And so this idea of
adaptability and agility
is going to be more
important now than ever.
And really, if you take
your core foundation--
the ability to
automate the processing
of data and bringing together
all of that variety of data
to help make better
decision process, to support
the decision making processes--
you do enable agility in
ways that really, truly
allow growth.
JON SOBEL: I'm so
glad you said that.
The notion of
continuous improvement,
which is the soul of
great manufacturing,
is exactly the same idea as
using data to get better.
And great manufacturers
think about getting
a little bit better every day.
And just like lean,
this is another tool
in the toolkit for doing it.
It's powerful.
It's powerful because once
you get that foundation set,
you can do so much
more beyond it.
But we don't have to change
the soul of manufacturing.
This is what
manufacturers do already.
They think, how do I
get better every day?
The other thing I would suggest
is have a big, bold vision.
Go big and fast.
Don't do everything upfront.
But be thinking about
more than just production.
Be thinking about the links
between production data
and everything else
in your organization.
And last-- and we call this out
as a kind of a special bullet
point--
partnering.
This is a comment
that's directed
at the really large companies.
I think a lot of manufacturers
partner very well.
If you think about how
good supply chains work,
those are essentially
partnerships.
But some very
large manufacturers
are accustomed to working
with kind of a monopoly
position in their industry.
I was speaking with
a CIO last week.
And I think he paid us
the greatest compliment
and in a way said the greatest
thing about his company
he could have said.
We're talking about
working together.
And I said, hey,
can I come see you?
When can I get on your calendar?
And he said, listen.
You come down here
whenever you want.
You're not a vendor.
You're a partner.
I'm trying to
change our company,
and the way I'm going to
do that is with partners.
That truly is a mindset--
if we think about
how procurement works
and all the stuff that
we do in large companies,
they're not built with
a partnership mindset.
They're built with
efficiency and they're built
to serve the organization.
When we're talking about
change and using data
and bringing in
technology, it's going
to be through partnership.
And companies that are good at
partnering-- and one of things
I admire so much about
Google is Google really
does partner with companies.
You all have thought about
changing so many industries
that you bring that
sensibility to the table.
And those manufacturers
that are doing this well
are definitely thinking
that way as well.
So those are some learnings.
We ought to just--
I'll take it from there.
JEN BENNETT: One quick question
or thought that I had, too--
we talked about data.
And you talked about
the fact that people can
handle large volumes of data.
But what we find in practice is
that people are handling them
through spreadsheets and through
notebooks and through word
of mouth.
And that's not really
how you handle big data.
Tell us a little bit
about some of the--
I'm super excited about the
technology that we offer.
But I'm even more
excited in some ways
about some of the secret
sauce that you have.
Can you give us a
little bit of insight
into some of the secret sauce?
JON SOBEL: Absolutely.
I appreciate the question.
I didn't want to dive
too deep into what we do
or into the tech, but
here's what's been missing.
If it were easy to do this, this
would have been done already
because companies
have been wrestling
with spreadsheets and data
lakes and data for years.
What's been missing is what we
call a canonical data model--
a systematic way to drop
into any manufacturing
and environment and
make sense of that data
through an automated data model.
And you need a model that can
handle different environments.
You can't just build a
model for a car plan.
Because then you could
understand part of a car plan,
but you can't go to
an electronics plant.
So you actually need a model
manufacturing as a discipline.
Bake that smarts
into your data model.
And then what you find--
so this was our journey.
We started working in a bunch
of plants around the world,
and they all made
different things.
And we needed a way
to understand it.
So we built
abstracted data models
and kept refining and improving
them through experience.
And then we had to pipe
in a huge amount of data.
Our company takes in about
15 billion data points a week
right now for our clients.
And that's a fraction of what
we'll do in a couple of years.
And you need software
automation to put
all that data in the
right place and to use
machine learning
and classification
techniques to understand it--
so basically, having
a representation
of what happens in a factory
built into math and software
so you can get empirical.
And we couldn't have
done this 10 years ago.
If you think of all the
different data types,
there's time series
data, there's alarms,
there's stuff in Excel,
there's text, there's pictures,
we now have the
technologies that
allow us to bundle and
attach all those data
points to these models.
And so that's
what's been needed.
And if you put that in kind
of the middle of everything
and then you extract the data,
put it through that engine,
and then, most important,
find relationships that
matter to a business person--
we don't just want to give
people a bunch of tools
and say, play with the data.
We want to take it to,
hey, the machines down.
Why?
Or something bad happened
and caused bad quality.
What's different in the system
for bad parts and good parts?
Or I got a recall.
Do I need to recall
everything, or just things
that were made last Thursday?
The answers are there in
the data if we can use it.
JEN BENNETT: You talked a
little bit throughout this
about the cultural
change and the leadership
and how that can really
help enable this.
But I'm guessing a
lot of our viewers
may not be the CEO
of their companies.
Maybe give us a
little bit of insight
of how everybody in their
role can really take advantage
of this and leverage this.
How is this applicable
to our viewers?
JON SOBEL: Sure.
So I think it's an
important question
because one of the
comments we had
earlier on one of our slides is
the importance of leadership.
Company leadership that
embraces this is critical.
I really appreciate
Jen's question
because not every leadership
team has necessarily
embraced this.
So what do you do if
you're in an organization
and you want to start making
progress with your data?
How do you do it?
And I think that's the majority
of organizations today.
So a couple of comments--
first, pick something that
you can get started with
and go fast.
And it's amazing how
once a screen pops up
and there's some evidence
that you can see something
that you couldn't see
before-- we used to joke about
in our earliest days,
we started working
at a big automotive
plant in Detroit.
And we called it factory TV.
As soon as there
was a picture up
and people could see what was
going on, they got excited.
So you got to
initiate the change.
JEN BENNETT: They got empowered.
JON SOBEL: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
And they could
make a difference.
So you got to
initiate the change.
I think that,
speaking very bluntly,
fear works really well--
letting your leadership team
know you're falling behind.
You're falling behind
as a management team.
Here's what other
companies in our--
you don't say it that way.
But here's what other companies
in our industry are doing.
And here's where we're going
to be if we don't keep up
is effective.
And then I think so much of
this is cross-functional.
So finding champions-- you and I
had an interesting conversation
before we started today about
command and control and how
increasingly, organizations--
Jamie Dimon just wrote a
great shareholder letter.
JP Morgan CEO said,
bureaucracy is a disease.
They need to get rid of it.
It's amazing.
Large companies are
realizing that to innovate,
we've got to open
up the channels.
And if you're somebody
who wants to make change
happen, find allies.
Find people who are influential.
Pick a project that
is within your budget.
Get it, light a spark, and
hopefully, people will pile on.
JEN BENNETT: And I also
think this whole idea
of democratization of data,
making data available--
as a leader, that's a choice
you can make pretty easily--
making data available.
And then what we've seen, even
within our own operation--
so we run data centers.
And we're a data-driven
organization anyways.
But we've had data availability.
We had engineers
who took the data
and built machine
learning models.
And now, our data
centers in the summer are
running 40% more efficiently--
40%.
I'm talking to manufacturers now
where every single percentage
point is large
amounts of money--
so 40% when you
make data available
and empower the individuals
within the organization.
So I think we have to
continuously champion
the return on investment
that we see just by making
data readily available.
And as you said,
the secret sauce
is making it usable as well.
So I think that's
really important.
I think we have just a couple
more minutes before we're
going to start the live Q&A.
So maybe one of the things
I wanted to talk about--
we talk a lot about analytics.
And there's many, many
companies out there
who are doing analytics.
Why do we still lack
this basic visibility
when these tools are
available and analytics
are readily available?
What is it that is
causing this problem?
JON SOBEL: So analytics
is one of those words.
It's a tough word.
I think you're absolutely right.
You asked me a few
minutes ago what's
the secret sauce to
making data useful.
If we can't put data in
the right building blocks,
we can't do the math we
need to do on top of things.
If I try to understand a bunch
of time series data points
and then relate that to
thousands of other things,
I'm not going to get anywhere.
And so let's think
of analytics as math.
There's no secret math
to understand a factory.
We can use a lot of good
statistical techniques
and machine learning
techniques on top of data.
There's probably
hundreds of companies
out there right now hand
waving in some form or another
about analytics.
But I'll tell you what's
been really interesting
in our journey.
The customers are smart.
Manufacturers have been working
with statistics and with data
for many years, and
they know whether or not
something can
analyze their data.
And so we try to stay away
from the software industry
terms for this because
they are so unhelpful.
What's really needed is--
here's the acid test.
For those of you who
are going to try stuff,
just demand that the
company is working
with you get you an answer fast
and that they do it scalably.
And stay away from
what you call it.
You'll know very
quickly whether or not
you can find patterns
and relationships
in your data or not.
JEN BENNETT: Yeah.
I think that's a
really great point.
One of the reasons why I'm
super excited about Sight
Machine and the
partnership with Google
is I worked with you
earlier on in my career
and through a couple of
very different problems
to test that-- to do
that as a test to say,
the real problem is not going
in and automating a line
or in gathering
data from one plant.
It's really about that problem
around can you really get it
across multiple and
across different problems
in a cost-effective way.
Because truly, that's the
growth that we're seeing,
the agility that we need.
That adaptability isn't
developing software
to solve one specific problem.
It's really that
secret sauce that you
have to be able to
build that model
to allow people to
use data in new ways
and solve new problems
with that same data.
And I think we're seeing
this across a number
of manufacturers
and really just want
to make sure that people are
aware that these technologies
exist.
And they're very
fruitful when applied.
And I think the last point
is that visibility is crucial
and that data is the first
step in that journey--
getting data visible.
You walked us through
that really nicely--
visibility, solving some
of those key problems
around quality,
and then moving up
into the point at which you can
start to use machine learning.
But honestly, when we talk
about learning, if you're not
collecting data and
getting it aggregated
in a way that can be
meaningful, machine learning
is not going to help you, right?
JON SOBEL: Right on.
JEN BENNETT: You need to
take these steps to get data.
And so that's really key.
Jon, it's been really great.
We're going to go and start
our Q&A, so stay tuned.
We'll be back in about a minute.
So thanks for joining us.
And we have some
really great questions.
We're really excited,
so let's get started.
First of all, Jon,
the first question
that came in-- what is
the technical insight
behind the Sight
Machine solution?
Is it just advanced
ETL for manufacturing?
So can you give us
a little bit of--
JON SOBEL: I love this question.
JEN BENNETT: This
is insider game.
JON SOBEL: Somebody knows
what they're doing here.
So yeah, the question is,
is it an advanced ETL?
The short answer is yes.
And I'm not an
engineer, so I want
to be careful not to get out
over my skis too much here.
But it's a unified
way of doing ETL
on the fly for the
manufacturing environment.
So instead of having to go
build a new model every time
we encounter a new
process or facility,
we configure a very
sophisticated stack
that invokes ETL that's
basically been prebuilt
but can be configured
for that environment.
There's a lot of other
pieces you need to have.
We're moving a lot of zeros
and ones around between Edge
and Cloud and all
kinds of other stuff.
But that question
is a great question
because it goes to
the heart of it, which
is having a flexible,
abstracted data
model that serves every
manufacturing environment.
And I think I'll just offer
this comment for our viewers.
This is how we're going to do
it in a bunch of industries.
The horizontal platforms
that are out there
are great for aggregating data.
But if you want to understand
farming or buildings or cities
or health care,
there needs to be
some smarts that's built
into the middle of the stack.
And that's what this
question goes to.
Great question.
JEN BENNETT: The next question--
how do you specifically get
data from the wide variety
of PLC manufacturers?
And the question
was, I understand
you can make a generic API.
But that doesn't actually
get the data off the PLCs
and into--
JON SOBEL: So this is another
really good technical question.
Let's zoom up really high here.
Three jobs to make data useful--
extract it, analyze
it, present it somehow.
This is a question
about extraction.
And we're partnering with some
great automation companies.
We get asked this all the time.
So people in the
controls environment
are used to very
rigid data structures.
And the intuition that
most of us have is,
oh, I got to work with all
that stuff inside of that.
Actually, all you need to
do is pull that data off
if you can get a digital
data stream off of a PLC.
We start to transform the
data once we pull it off.
So we just need to get it off.
And 80% of PLCs in North America
are made by the top three PLC
manufacturers.
So once you know how to talk
to Siemens, Allen-Bradwell--
JEN BENNETT: Bradley, yeah--
JON SOBEL: Yeah, Allen-Bradley--
Rockwell, Allen-Bradley,
or Mitsubishi,
you got 80% of them.
So it's about
extracting the data,
not trying to work with
inside the controls code,
and then transforming
it through what we do.
JEN BENNETT: I think the
other point that you made,
which I think is really
important-- yes, there's
data coming off of the
machines and the PLC data.
There's also a lot of
other data floating around
the manufacturing
shop floor that
may not be coming from a PLC.
And so I think part of the
value of the Sight Machine
solution built on
Google Cloud is really
being able to handle
that variety of data.
It's not just time series data
off the machine and alarm data
off the machine.
So I think that's also
important to keep in mind.
JON SOBEL: And well said.
Let's just hammer
the point here.
It would be very
dangerous to build
a solution around one piece of
automation or one data source.
Data is coming off of operators.
It's in quality systems.
It's in your automation
and controls.
And we've seen this
wave of solutions
that's been built for
data of a certain type.
But the way Google
thinks about data
and the we think about
data is data is data.
And so we ought to be
getting a solution that's
open and agnostic.
And companies are
very smart about this.
They do not want to be locked
into XYZ Company's data
platform that only goes with
that company's equipment.
That's a horrible business
model for a customer.
Great business model
if you can get away
with it selling the
equipment, but it's not
going to work in a factory.
There's too many things.
So I think you're dead on.
JEN BENNETT: Great.
Next question-- what tools,
technology platforms are
available to specifically
support organizations
in highly-regulated
environments-- for example,
medical devices, pharma--
to really help begin this
digital transformation?
JON SOBEL: So
highly-regulated industries
are probably one of the
best places to start.
The need for traceability
from end to end--
so if we think about
highly-regulated industries,
it's usually something
where there's
some risk if the product
isn't built right-- so drugs,
increasingly food,
medical device.
All of this is
production we want
to understand holistically and
with a great degree of control
and granularity.
There are a bunch
of disparate tools
out there right now
as people prepare
for increasing regulation.
There's a lot of
point solutions.
What's needed and what I
think you're starting to see
is a way to knit
together all these data
sources without having
to go change historians
or various compliance techniques
the company have used.
So you can think of all of these
islands of tools that exist.
And we need some water to
connect it up, and we're there.
If we get the data out
of all of these islands,
we can do very powerful
things with it.
That is exactly what a
regulator wants to see.
A regulator wants
to know, can I see
how this batch was made so that
I know that this batch is bad
but the other ones are good.
Can I see that data?
You already have all that data.
JEN BENNETT: And you know,
I think one of the things--
I have a real
passion around this,
and I know you do as well.
But this idea that not
too distant in the future,
we're going to be connecting
up all of these data sources
so that things like recalls--
I know that we will
look back and say,
how crazy it was how we found
out about recalls, right?
We just heard about this
cluster of things that happened
in a particular population.
And then it takes months
to get to the point
where-- the manufacturing side
is just one small piece of it.
As we start to really
bring together data,
I think these
patterns, this ability
to really find
problems quicker is
going to be game
changing in our world.
JON SOBEL: I have a
colleague-- our CMO, Syed Hoda,
always talks about
how when Samsung
had terrible problems with its
batteries, you get on a plane.
And the first thing
they'd say is,
don't bring this
device on the plane.
And the whole world was
marketing against this quality
problem.
Unfortunately, it
took several months
to figure out what went wrong.
What you just said is going
to change how companies
get control of these problems.
And we're going to
look back one day
and go, man, that
was the Stone Ages.
JEN BENNETT: Yeah.
Probably have time
for one more question.
So we don't own many
of our own plants,
but use contract manufacturers.
How can you drive change
across the virtual supply
chain involving many partners?
I know you know
this really well.
JON SOBEL: I mean, we
both love this question
because the supply
chain is really
the right frame of reference.
This requires some cooperation.
I think good supply
chains already
have trust and cooperation.
Those supply chains
that can handle it
simply need to share data.
We have seen some manufacturers
in the middle of the supply
chain generate huge amounts
of credibility and confidence
in their production
because they share data
with their customers.
So our very first customer--
we started our company
in Southeast Michigan.
Our very first customer
was bending metal,
selling to the big
three, and realized
that if they showed data
about their production
and the control over
quality they had,
that would be a
competitive advantage
in their supply chain.
They were getting 7% or 8%
of the bids that they put in.
And once they revealed
the data, they
were able to get all kinds of
high-value, higher-margin work
because they generated trust.
So this is good for everybody.
If you're confident in your
production, share your data.
If you're the head
of the supply chain,
ask your partners to
share it with you.
We can all be
better if we do it.
It's not easy.
It's a little scary sometimes,
but that's how you get good.
JEN BENNETT: And I think,
too, that manufacturers have--
this is something
that is becoming
more and more important is
around getting that data.
It really is critical.
And really having suppliers--
giving them a preferred
supplier if you
have that better integration--
I think these are things from
a business model perspective
that you can start
to look at as well.
JON SOBEL: One last
comment real quick.
There's all kinds of
fights about ownership.
You own your own data.
It's your data.
We can share it.
We can use it.
We can put up a license
regime around it.
This is a totally
solvable problem.
JEN BENNETT: Yeah, no, we agree.
And we have one
minute, actually.
So I'm going to take this
last one really quickly.
Our organization does not have
many data science resources--
we talk a lot about this, Jon--
especially at plant locations.
How can we drive
better decision making
without these capabilities?
I'll quickly jump in and say,
from a Google perspective,
we understand that
data science resources
are very difficult to get.
And so one of the
things that we're
trying to do with our
technology as well
is to provide
better tooling that
enables the democratization
of data science capabilities
and so making that
more attainable.
But maybe you can give
us a quick insight.
JON SOBEL: I love this question.
We went to a plant a year
ago at a very large company
that had 200 data
scientists on the line.
I called up our CTO and
said, uh oh, can we help them
understand anything?
They have 200 data scientists.
He said, good news.
They don't know anything if
they have 200 data scientists.
You don't need that many.
And if companies like
us do our job right,
we're going to give you really
helpful, useful insight.
There's a real range.
A few gets a lot done.
And if you want
to invest in more,
it's going to be a great field.
JEN BENNETT: So many
thanks for joining us.
If you're interested,
the next webinar
is Kubeflow, machine learning
at Kubernetes-- machine
learning really important
in manufacturing as well.
So please stay tuned for
that session as well.
Thanks for joining.
[MUSIC PLAYING]